at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands shake this
episode is brought to you by LinkedIn
and their job recruitment platform which
offers a smarter system for the hiring
process
if you've ever hired anyone or tempted
to do it you know that finding the right
people can be extremely difficult and if
you don't have a direct referral from
someone you trust you're left to use job
boards that don't really offer any
real-world networking approach and what
I mean by that is in contrast LinkedIn
which is the world's largest
professional network has a built-in
ecosystem that allows you to not only
search for employees but also interact
with them and their connections and
their former employers or colleagues in
a way that closely mimics real-life
communication more than 70 percent of
the workforce in the u.s. uses LinkedIn
and more than 22 million professionals
view and apply to LinkedIn every single
week unlike generic job boards LinkedIn
considers skills experience and location
to match you with candidates making it
easier to find quality candidates and
maybe above all you can directly contact
a candidate's connections to get a good
sense of if they are a good fit for your
business
so visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim
and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post that's linkedin.com
forward slash tim TI m for $50 off
this episode is brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin Rose I've known him
forever some of you know and he showed
up at my gate at my house a while back
and he looked fantastic I asked him as a
dude you look great what the hell have
you been up to because he's always doing
a weird diet or another but it only
lasts like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't worry about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute etc
new classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike
includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not
and it fits with no problem so peloton
is offering all of you guys listeners of
the Tim Ferriss show a special offer and
it is actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say mat
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so this
hundred dollars off is a very legit so
if you want to get in your workouts if
you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high-intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone
check out pillows on one pallet on comm
and enter the code Tim again that's oh
and E PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter
the code tim at checkout to receive $100
off any accessories including the shoes
that you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim hello boys and
girls this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
my guest today is Nicholas Thompson on
twitter @ NX Thompson he is the
editor-in-chief of Wired under his
leadership wired has launched a
successful paywall a snapchat channel
and an AM P stories edition if I'm
pronouncing that correctly I'm going to
serve its amp or amp e we'll get back to
that has also been nominated for
National Magazine Awards in design and
feature writing
Thompson is a contributor for CBS News
and regularly appears on CBS this
morning he is also a co-founder of the
Atavist which I've had contact with
going way back in the day a national
magazine award-winning digital
publication prior to joining Wired
Thompson served as editor of New Yorker
calm for 2012 to 2017 before the New
Yorker Thompson was a senior editor at
Wired where he assigned and edited the
feature story The Great Escape which was
the basis for the oscar-winning film
Argo in 2009 his book the ha
and the Dove Paul nitsa George Kennan
and the history of the Cold War was
published a critical acclaim in Feb 2008
een Thompson co-wrote Wired's cover
story inside the two years that shook
Facebook and the world an 11,000 word
investigation based on reporting with
more than 50 current and former Facebook
employees Nick welcome to the show that
was amazing my pleasure and I appreciate
you correcting or at least informing my
pronunciation of the the subtitle of
your book this is not an easy name to
pronounce I was a favorite story about
it as I was giving a talk about my book
in Wisconsin I'm like 10 minutes in this
guy runs out I tend to mix up one of the
characters mumbles my grandfather
Pulitzer this guy runs out and at the
end I ask the hostess like why'd it why
that guy leave looks mean you said he
thought he was going to hear from each
his grandson Oh spelling so there are
many different questions that I want to
ask and I have many many in front of me
that I will ask but I thought I would
start with something that I chanced upon
when doing homework for this which I'll
lead into with just reading the line and
it is he is also an instrumental
guitarist who used to supplement his
journalism by playing on subway
platforms is that true that you used to
play music to supplement your writing
income presumably I guess this is the
wrong word cuz I actually made more
money yeah I used to play when I was a
young journalist let's say ages 21
through 24
I played a fingerstyle guitar on the
platforms in New York and you could make
a good amount of money you know you know
I'd make $20 an hour you meet people
it's really fun you learn a lot about
the city it's good sort of forced to
practice for multiple hours you learn a
lot about the trains I had a great time
doing that did you pick up any best
practices for busking I mean there are
many people who play on the platforms
I'm sure they make different rates so
what
the what is what were some of the best
practices are protein things which is
kind of interesting is to figure out the
style of music you play and the
demographics you're trying to hit so if
you're playing like super familiar stuff
if you're doing kind of Beatles covers
you can go in a hallway right where
people will hear you for two seconds and
walk by or you can be on a train
platform where the trains come every two
minutes right because people were just
here yesterday give you money you're
doing what I was doing which is like
weird instrumental guitar music the
people will always like if they get a
couple of minutes uninterrupted you've
got to find a platform where you know
there may not be a ton of traffic but
where the trains don't come very often
so for me the place that turned out to
be the best was the l-train platform on
6th Avenue and 14th Street people know
New York to be able to visualize it and
the most good about that is that the L
train comes relatively infrequently it's
one platform with both trains going on
either side of it it's not a split
platform so you get people who are
booked going both West and East and then
it was kind of like perfect for me
demographically because it's where all
the gay guys in Chelsea get off and then
we're all kind of the sort of vegan
young hipsters are heading to
Williamsburg so I got like a lot of
demographics you're gonna like a stop if
they see a young guy playing guitar and
possibly give money so that was I really
spent a lot of time thinking it through
and out with what I like so what you do
is you try to get there you know you
don't want to be there at like 3 o'clock
when schools get out because everybody's
lives
it's crazy people are yelling nobody can
hear you the kids are jumping the kids
kind of make fun of you but you
definitely want to be there during
commute time and you definitely want to
be there at like 9 o'clock at night and
this is the rules at least back when I
was doing it a lot you know once you get
a spot you keep that spot so it's until
you either get bored or have to pee you
have it so you you try to come right at
like 3:30 and then hold it until 10:00
if you can and did you ever contemplate
going the beatles route playing more
popular music so that you could get
money for a few seconds of attention or
or did you choose your your musical
selection for other reasons besides the
20
an hour you know it was better the thing
is that I'm not good at Beatles covers
right and like I have like a limited of
a very member stations in I have a
limited skill set but I'm very good at
writing my own like multi-channel
acoustic instrumental guitar songs and I
I'm really bad at reading music and
playing other stuff so I never had that
choice but it would be an interesting
choice right do you go for if you have
the capacity to do both which do you
choose do you choose the one that gets
you more money and is a little less
emotionally fulfilling it's like a
typical choice we have in the thousand
moments of life unfortunately didn't
have to do that in this particular
subway music stage of my career why did
you choose writing full-time instead of
music full-time it seems like both paths
are presumably difficult right I mean
you are a creator in both paths I don't
know if that's a bad question but it
just comes to mind it's like you seem
very talented question if you know and I
think that what was interesting is that
they were kind of competitive with me
right and so the things that go into how
much time you prioritize playing music
how much time do you prioritize being a
journalist include factors like how much
do you make per hour but also as time
goes by how do you expect your life and
ambitions to grow and the thing about
being a musician is that I kind of I
could see the endpoint right I didn't
think I was going to become a
transcendentally good musician I didn't
see I think career where I was like
changed the way music was made or you
know create a new sound but I didn't I
didn't think that even if I could go to
myself to completely for 10 years I'd
ever reach that high place so I could
kind of see the max that I would get
through whereas in journalism the max
was quite a bit higher so as the is the
earnings began to equal out as it began
to earn more as a journalist I started
to gravitate more more towards that so
it was a combination of having some
success as a journalist and also
thinking through like what would a life
of the musician be like versus what
would life as a journalist be like for
somebody with my skills and as I said
earlier my skills as a musician are
limited right I could I could do well at
one thing but I didn't think I was going
to really make a life work that way do
you recall any particular moments
whether it could be at any point your
life really where you thought to
yourself this writing thing or this
editing thing something related to
long-form text is something that I could
really be excellent at or this this is
something that I think I could make a
good living doing because I'm I I can be
exceptional at this was there a moment
where you had that thought that would
sort of compel you to pursue that say
instead of the music yeah you know the
funny thing is that in my mind to those
foundational years let's say from when
in the time I graduated college to the
time I completely committed to it as it
to be a journalist it was 29 it wasn't
it wasn't always music versus journalism
you know in those early years of his
music versus journalism and other things
and then it was journalism versus other
things you know I thought you want to
finish college I thought I was gonna be
sort of an environmental activist or I
might go into politics and I got kind of
put and tracked into journalism kind of
a slightly odd way which we can get into
so it was really only at about 29 when I
got hired by Wired
and started to do a good job at it in
stores and when I started writing
writing my book about innocent Canon
that I began to feel really comfortable
confident about it as a career choice
you said I think you just attract into
journalism in an odd way so I can't I
can't pick that up or I can't not pick
that up right yes let's jump let's jump
in yeah it's it's super bizarre so I
when I was in college I was focused very
much on being like a good college
student and succeeding at college and
like going into student government and
getting good grades but I was to degree
that's strange when I look back did not
think at all about
happen right I went to Stanford out of
graduate school fellowship like I did
well in college but I've prepared for
life both college
extraordinarily badly and so I graduate
and then maybe the fall after I graduate
where I'm playing guitar I get I meet
somebody at a party and sort of get
surprisingly hired as an associate
producer at 60 minutes which is a great
job and so I moved to New York I show up
at CBS for 60 minutes is and within an
hour I'm fired
I'm living within an hour your fire
within an hour
what what was the offense I was being
hired into position sort of beyond my
stature it was very strange and in
retrospect it's one of those things
where I was I was treated kind of
awfully but I didn't understand it I
asked twenty-two so I go I show up I'm
still remember and this guy's name is
still chef Larry's like who are you I'm
like I'm the new Associate Producer I'm
working under Steve Groft there's like
what have you done in television before
I was like nothing you know and it's
like well what have you done
professionally before I was like nothing
I just graduated and he's like and we
hired you as associate producer I was
like yeah you know I did these
interviews and left seven newscasts he's
like you fired me out of the building
Wow
I think it's worse so that's that's I
think December of 1997 I graduated
college in June and I descent that's
December 97 so I'm like huh what am I
going to do now one of my best friends
from college was starting graduate
school in the fall and he was about to
leave for Africa and so I was like I'm
coming with you so I go and I get my
vaccinations and within you know two
weeks I'm on a plane and then I get
kidnapped immediately upon landing in
Africa right i slide us and and i take a
boat to Tangiers and I pull out my
guitar to subway platform in Tangiers
I'm alone at this point seen in northern
Morocco um a guy comes up to me he's
like hey you know my family plays music
you want to come home with me I'm like
great yeah sure I've got a day here
before I'm 60 my friend and it turns out
that he's like he's a drug dealer he
locks me in this room and he has these
khakha me
plans where he wants me to distribute
his drugs around America and he makes me
a fish head it's it's all very peculiar
but it's definitely not what it's
definitely not come home to my family
and play guitar and so I've stopped to a
feeling rocky start in Africa and
eventually he dumps me and says enough
of this guy like you I'm not getting
what I want hi to you and just like
dumps me and lets me make my way to the
train station but the funny thing about
that hold on let me pause her so was he
like this guy is definitely not equipped
to be a proper drug dealer for me in the
United States me what was the kind of
the straw that broke the camel's back or
he's just like enough of you I'm letting
you go and what it was did you have an
approach how did you get out of that I
was very confused I think what happened
was you know I don't think he had like
begun that day saying I'm gonna kidnap
in America I think was more like he saw
me sitting there was like let's see what
happens if I take this guy right and
then I go there and he goes through my
stuff he like goes through all my stuff
like looking for money and he finds that
I've only got I think it was $50 in cash
and there's no traveler's checks and
fortunately I had a backpack that had
like the smuggling sections built into
it and so my passport and like the
valuable stuff were in there and so I
think he went through all my stuff
and decided that I was like and I clear
a traveler who was useless I don't know
what answers I gave him about you know
being the drug meal for him that turned
him off but it didn't work out was
important and the outcome wasn't what I
wanted so so he dumped me got rid of me
and then a great thing is that I then
had a story and so I turned that
experience
and some other experiences I had an
after I and then spent several months
traveling with my friend and some other
friends I turned those into an essay for
the Washington Post so suddenly I had
journalistic clips and so kind of
inadvertently having been fired from
journalism I used to the experience that
followed to get clips and then I came
back a played guitar
and then those clips led to a job as the
editor of the Washington Monthly which
was a place that hired sort of young and
this is people into roles with low
playing roles but high responsibilities
where you learn a lot so that was how I
got going since realism it was very
bizarre how did you pitch the Washington
Post or why did you end up
was it a cold query or just a cold email
to one of the editors he found on the
masthead or how did you go about getting
this published I think that I think it
was a cold query I know that I had
talked to some journalists before I left
remember talking to me from the Boston
Globe it was in Boston about you know if
interesting things happened to me would
there be would it be possible to write
stories some locations in Africa and so
I had gotten some advice but I think I
think just get kidnapped who would make
a really good material my friend said to
me he's like well you know to have that
experience it only leaves 60 dollars
it's kind of worth it shaken by the
whole thing I was like oh you jerk but
he was totally right it turned out to be
like a really interesting experience for
a mere $60 I saw this woman in New York
City at one point walking around with
the t-shirt this is the crop top that
said bad decisions make good stories and
I didn't quite know how to take the
shirt like in the context of her walking
around with it but yeah true for
stand-up comedians and it would seem
true for people in northern Africa
considering people perhaps a path in
journalism yeah I let's jump forward and
I'm sure this is going to be very
nonlinear and how he bounced around but
one of the things that I mentioned in
the intro was this piece The Great
Escape that later was turned into Argo
and yes when I was doing some writing on
this
a line that jumped out at me that I
wanted to dig into was at Wired at least
at the time every pitch was graded on a
scale of 1 to 6 by everyone on staff and
there's a meeting where these story
ideas are pitched and are then presented
rather in reverse order of their scores
along with their standard deviations
which is fantastic but could you subject
to that pitch grading process and oh my
god tell us the story of the Great
Escape because my understanding is it
wasn't a it wasn't an immediate point to
center field hit home run type of story
but I'm most curious in the grading
process and how you guys did that but
that was the wired was run by this guy
named Chris Anderson who had been a
writer at the Economist and just a
really high IQ Silicon Valley type and a
very mathematical way of looking at the
world and so this efficiency mechanism
he brought into the pitch process was to
run it like sort of a false democracy
under a dictatorship so the final
decision was made entirely by Chris
whether a story was the saying or not
but when you wrote a pitch it would be
sent to everybody on staff and everybody
would vote on it and grade it and the
theory was if you it was kind of a
wisdom of crowds theory then if you got
everybody's vote you could immediately
tell what was great and what was that
and that I think he genuinely believed
that one of the things that happens in
meetings is that you spend a lot of time
discussing stuff that 95% of the room
hates but since only a couple of people
talk you can't quite determine that
quickly and so this is a way of
determining what is the stuff that 95%
of the room loves and 95% of the room
hates immediately which is a super
interesting thing right it's like
theoretically a great thing to do the
problem with that is that it can be
really the moral I think when your
pitches do badly it's okay to get
rejected by the other and cheek but they
have your pitch you know created badly
by all your colleagues it's kind of
so for the Great Escape I remember I
know this really well so just a writer
Joshua Behrman who's he's a great stuff
for this American like Sherlock on some
wonderful essays he's a little you know
we've quite a bit younger than remember
he sent me a bunch of pitches I can't
remember what the whole packet was maybe
some e3 ideas but one was and that's a
spy he's got the story of a crazy escape
from Iran and then another one I
remember on the same email was I think
Stalin tried to create a half-man
half-ape army and so like the two things
were together like should we investigate
Stalin's half-man half-ape army or
should we investigate like this escape
from Iran and so through whatever
process of conversations between editor
and writer dresses I decided to pursue
the escape from Iran and I pitched it at
the meeting and I knew it was gonna do
badly right because it wasn't a wired
story right it's like from the 1970s
it's not about you know how Amazon and
artificial intelligence machines and I
was just wasn't core wired and it said
everybody voted it really badly right
the scores are won 2-6 it probably got a
score of like two something on the other
hand Bob Cohen it was the executive
editor the number two person there I
remember at the pitch meeting just being
like it's not wired but I love it let's
do it and so he just sort of muscled it
so again it was democracy under a
dictatorship and the dictators wanted to
do the story because it was such a cool
so manifestly a you know riveting
narrative so we ended up a sign in it
Josh wrote it did a great job published
it and then Hollywood took an interest
so a few follow-ups what makes a good
pitch
so when Josh sent you this pitch let's
just assume for the time being that it
was it was a good set of pitches we
could talk about is gonna sound funny to
people who don't have background we
could talk more about Stalin it was a
real missed opportunity like we would
have found out there was a half-man
half-ape army which would be an amazing
story but not only that but you have a
correct me if I'm wrong this it's from
the internet so who knows but a long
friendship with Stalin's daughter is
that right yeah
that is that is very true happy to talk
about that yes that Lana and I were
friends for many many years
putting aside the half-man half-ape army
of Stalin question mark what makes a
good pitch if a writer is pitching
someone like you what does a good pitch
look like what are the what are the
ingredients what are common mistakes
that make something a bad pitch however
you want to kind of answer that for
folks yeah yep so a couple of elements
that I appreciate are when the writer
gives options right so what Josh had
done and that he know is he had sent you
know three ideas which i think is really
great
all right and it's useful to be able to
pick and it gives you a sense of the
person's range of mind another element
that's very useful is the element of
pitch that answers the question why am I
the person to do this so in Josh's pitch
the reason he was the person to do it is
that he had will found something that no
one had known before and to had unique
access to the key character right had
access to the spine okay 20 minutes I
think I suppose is next so that's
another important element and then the
third is understanding what the magazine
is trying to do in the section to try to
write for so what wired was trying to do
and it's teacher well then as now was
tell very important stories about how
technology is changing the world but
also tell things that are cinematic and
fun to read and that are part of the
wired world so this story you know the
Great Escape wasn't going to change the
way you think about tech but it had
characters right it had emotional
residents it had like there was a movie
you could play in your mind as you have
been asked like later you know show
without question and that's often a
question I'll ask to the story so how
will there be to be able to visualize
how will they be emotionally attached to
it why will they care about the
characters you introduced in the
beginning what happens to then at the
end so a good pitch is something where
you're writing it away that makes the
editor convinced that you'll be able to
write well it shows why you have special
knowledge or special insight or special
access it shows why the story is new and
that you know it's structured so that
the pitch clearly fits the aims and
goals of the magazine or publication
you're writing for do the writers also
indicate or is it just assumed a given
length
or a lead time for completion is any of
that included in that initial pitchers
that does that come does that come later
or is it just usually yeah the public
comes later if it's somebody who I've
worked with specifically they may say
hey I'd like to do this this month or I
want to fitted in my calendar or you
know I'm planning to go to location TK
and June I could do it then but normally
it's more like this is a story I'd like
to do in you know the next reasonable
timeframe so I just want to back up for
a second for people who don't know what
TK means okay
as I understand it means to come but
it's spelled TK so that you can find it
very easily when you search for it
that's my understanding
at least and yes because very few words
in the English language have T and K so
you can do a ctrl F and find the things
that you need to spot really quickly so
for people who are wondering oh hi
TK you know a friend of mine Neil
Strauss will turn off his Wi-Fi when he
writes and not interrupted for
fact-checking and certain types of
research and just drop TK in throughout
the piece and then do that as a batching
process later just for people that are
like yeah so for people who are
wondering about that he also uses an app
called freedom to block the internet so
that yeah you'd better disrupt yourself
is a good thing to do is now you just
described Chris Anderson's process which
fits personality and I've met Chris
before a very smart guy what is your
process how does your story pitch
process differ it's pretty similar
actually I mean we've gotten rid of the
scores and the standard deviations I
thought that probably introduced a
little bit too much stress and
unnecessary anxiety for people but I
there is that there is value to it I can
see so what we do is a similar process
so the writer will work with an editor
and they'll come up with the pitch we
try to make sure that they're under the
page just to respect everybody's time
and because constraints need to better
work in general
so people send in a one-page [ __ ] we
sit around in a room lots of people are
invited editor the editors will be
signing the stories kind of sit around
the main table story comes up and we
talk about it we talk about what have
you got answer questions will the writer
really be able to do that what uh
then what are common unanswered
questions sorry to interrupt like a lot
a lot of pitches will they'll be missing
that element of how of what the scenes
will actually be right and who how the
characters will develop right it's like
here's a big idea here's an important
thing that happened and I'm gonna write
5,000 words about it and there's almost
no thing that is big or important enough
that you can write 5,000 words about it
if you don't have like specific scenes
and visual moments where you could pull
a person in and again this is a wired
feature so I can we run with Web stories
we have a much more informal process
eventually things inside a book where
there's a more informal process but you
know we only run four features a month
of 48 of them a year so we do discuss
them all and whether you know they'll be
able to pull it off and how will the
chronology work and there's a lot of
discussions about the writers because an
incredibly talented magazine teacher
writer sort of a subset of ideas they
could write about as a lot larger than
some of those more limited skills and
experience in this particular craft so
we'll talk about okay when would have
you read by this person who I remember
reading that story I didn't take it
totally worked or I read that story it
didn't work very quite well so that's
how it works we all talk about it and
then afterwards I'll speak with the
executive editor and a couple of other
editors and we'll make a decision red
light green light we're like really
we're going to talk about atomists the
startup that I mentioned but I'm going
to tie I'm going to tie it in here
because my understanding is that you've
had a decent amount of exposure to two
feature pieces being optioned for film
and Argo or rather the Great Escape
which then became Argos is one such
example a lot of a lot of writers dream
of having things optioned if so my
climate coach my questions I suppose our
a is it a dream worth having
or is it just almost uniformly
disappointing or somewhere in between
and then be if you if you were having
something optioned of yours what are the
deal points or this the the deal
structures that you would pay attention
to oh that's interesting okay so yeah
wired I think very few stories from
Wired were option before 2007 and then
wired start to get a reputation as a
place where stories were optioned and
has had a good amount of success since
then the atomist which we started in
2009 has had success from the get-go I
mean it's something like 25 percent of
the stories that run in the animist have
an option to Hollywood which is a crazy
crazy percent I think it's 30 percent
and so is it a dream worth having yes it
is a dream worth having the most
important thing is having a good agent
who has actually sold films before not
like a lot of writers don't know the
right agents and having the right agent
just is utterly transformative it takes
you from you know almost no chance to a
very good cancer so having an agent who
has actually had success selling
magazine stories in Hollywood before is
really important and so what we did at
the atomists is we just started out with
the agent who had had a lot of success
the same guy that we had used Adam that
I my co-founder ever a little bit of
writer for Wired and that I had used at
Wired and so we just brought him in with
the auditors from the from the Gecko
fairly early on and when you're looking
at the deal points you know what you
want is you know there's a whole series
of stages along the way where you get
different paths right you get an initial
amount of money and then you get certain
renewals and then if the script is
written to that if the movie is made and
so what you want are you want to make
sure that high quality people are sort
of being added at each step so that it's
more likely to move from A to B to C to
B and that you you don't kind of fall
for the dream where it's like alright
we'll give you a thousand dollars now
they're a million dollars to make it
and there's almost no chance we'll make
it right you want to make sure that you
get paid real money up front because
even a really good script facility that
people are taps to that's a fairly low
percentage chance of getting through
definitely certainly it seems that way
and yet there are some that make it
through yeah like the Great Escape for
instance I what are there any other
clauses that are particularly important
and I've never I've had four for the
first book that I did I've had folks
approached me about film adaptation but
it seemed like at least in the
structures that were being offered it
was very much a lock-up period with
almost no monetary compensation with no
guarantee that they would actually do
anything with it in the sense that the
reversion of rights clause became really
important to consider much like yeah if
you're a product developer or an
inventor and you develop something that
you want to license to a larger company
there's nothing compelling them to spend
marketing dollars on it or to develop it
or push it in less or I should say you
increase the likelihood of that if you
have that dictated in the terms of the
contract and then some reversion of
rights clause it's I suppose what I'm
wondering is how much time in your mind
do you allow for a story to float out
there in the ether of say Hollywood
before you can you pull it back in some
fashion or or allow it to take a
different path potentially because I
know friends who are writers who've had
stuff just float around and so once I
was attached but oh no they're not
attached because they're busy and then
this person's attached and no they're
not because they had a conflict and it
just goes on and on and on for years and
years and years is there and yeah
yeah any / any ways that you've found to
mitigate against that in any way yeah so
I'm not you know this is not my area of
expertise but a couple of things one I
think that the value of before you
publish and before you put it up for
auction
of locking a few things down is really
important making sure you have the life
rights to the central character that you
you've negotiated you know in the
example in the Argos story it was really
important to Josh had locked up right -
Toni amended his story so that after the
story ran it wasn't like somebody else
could do the same story but without Josh
attached to it because josh and Toni
came as a package and so they had
negotiated to deal together and so
that's a really important thing to make
sure that you have as much as you can
the rights to that particular story
buttoned up because it gives you just
much more leverage if potential bidders
aren't like you know I can probably do
this without NIC markup I do this
without buying the rights to make story
because it's public domain or so talking
to an agent and working through that I
think is really important and then just
knowing that you know there's no part of
the world where people kind of tell more
baloney stories about how this is about
the stars that are coming on Hollywood
like there's so many oh yes you know
will attach tranches for Coppola right
but let's do this we'll do that and if
they're not lying it's just never true
right do you really not have it written
down I think where people get caught is
they sort of fall for that and what you
need to do is you need to have an agent
you need to have an auction you need to
have a formal process you need to get
more than one person excited and you
have two people bidding then you have
much more leverage on making sure that
you get terms where you get either a
decent amount of money or a pretty good
guarantee that will be made you know
what we did to be out of this is we
ultimately set up a first-look deal
meaning we work with a Hollywood studio
that T's is an annual guarantee every
year to be able to read the stories
before everybody else and a happy
opportunity to bid on them and so that
was a way of getting guaranteed income
making sure that somebody was interested
and kind of locking the process in a way
that worked for us that's great yeah
that's very smart
I didn't didn't realize that for people
who are wondering agent agent agent I
keep on hearing agent how do I get an
agent how do I figure out who the agents
are I'd love to hear
I'd love to hear your thoughts a very
good starting place is to in my
experience the sign up for IMDB Pro and
look at the credits of
different films that you've enjoyed or
perhaps screenplays that that you might
be interested in and try to trace back
the roots that way I am DB then provides
say contact information for different
actors directors and so on and you'll
start to see certain names that pop up a
lot like William Morris Endeavor WME CAA
operators arts agency UTA and so on but
would you have any other recommendations
for people who want to educate
themselves about that side of the
business per se my only other
recommendation would be to find friends
you friends of friends who have actually
had success and say who sold it and I do
this much more in the book publishing
world with a higher percentage of my
friends have sold books where you know
you I know you sold the book what agent
did you use and would you recommend him
or her and then if you've got five
people who sell books you ask them all
couple a name to come up and you go meet
with them see you click with who you get
a good bond without being the best you
know the best possible agent is somebody
who has a track record and who actually
likes you and cares about you and
sometimes those things are kind of like
inversely related because they have a
track record they've something class
they're not gonna care about you so
you're just gonna figure out how to find
somebody who's both good and responsive
so on a segue to The New Yorker for
probably more than a few minutes since
here I find the New Yorker fascinating
as I do wired but in a 2015 interview
you'd said and again fact fact correct
as needed but the most encouraging thing
we found is that the stories were
prouder of the stories we put more
effort in to attract more readers so
that the I'd love to talk about what
that means if you could elaborate on
that because I as someone who personally
speaking for myself enjoys long-form
content and make some effort to resist
the temptation to listicle myself to
death in hopes of their eyeballs and
clicks what what what did that mean and
how did you foster that that's that's
that was like one of the most important
kind of existential those debates and
findings at the New Yorker so I started
the New Yorker on the print side when we
really didn't when the magazine hadn't
put a lot of effort into having an
ambitious daily website at the website
of New Yorker mostly just published the
print stories and some of them were
behind to pay well to them or not and
then as part of this process where David
became David Remnick became much more
excited about daily journalism and the
importance of having a website
potentially I was moved over to run the
website work with a bunch of people and
so the initial challenge was you know
can you publish daily content because
the magazine is put together by somebody
people with so much experience and the
website was this kind of startup within
the organization where you have to be a
lot scrappier you're paying people you
know in New York or writer will get
several dollars a word to write five
thousand words so you're looking at
$15,000 a story and on the website
you're looking at $200 a story so can
you produce content for that $200 that
won't sort of detract from the other
stuff and that's a challenge writing you
have to figure out what is the DNA how
long how long were those stories insert
into the online maybe 800 words you know
a thousand words I mean that was
actually initially conversation like if
you make them 300 words you know will it
actually detract more then if you make
it 800 words you should you make the web
stories more like the long print stories
or less like the long term stories and
so there's a lot of back-and-forth this
is kind of a central debate in my mind
for several years right how do you make
daily web content that feels of a piece
with the New Yorker magazine is since
been around for 85 years and has such an
incredible instance of great stories and
so back to the initial question over
time we found that what got the most
readership that worked the best in every
sense were smart pieces of analysis of
what was happening right now
ideally written by the same people who
work for the magazine and they would
spend
you're far less time per word on their
website and then with the magazine
stares that they would feel related they
feel other pieces you know Phillip
gravis wrote a web piece about a terror
attack that it just happened it would
feel enough like a soul critics magazine
feature and the readers would appreciate
it and so ultimately our strategy became
getting the staff writers to write
regular posts hiring people who could
write very quickly could write at the
cadence of the web but who had similar
profiles to The New Yorker staff writers
moving John Cassidy for example who was
a magazine staff writer writes a column
every day for the website which is great
really reliable to have to know that
every day you have a terrific column by
the super smart well-respected guy same
with Amy Davidson who are gonna see your
editor so bringing over people bringing
in new people getting some of the staff
writers and what we found was that that
the stuff people liked was the best
stuff we published and that was really
heartening like people didn't want to go
to New Yorker calm so you read to sort
of click through sensationalized
slideshows they want to come to New
Yorker to read the smart interesting
things and that was great because when
your business incentives aligned with
your sort of journalistic incentives
you're in a much happier place and if
the two are sort of run perpendicular to
each other so I would love to get your
help encouraging people to do more long
form and by people I mean publishers to
foster that type of kind of patient
editorial and in some cases and and so
I'm gonna make this really personal I've
thought a lot about hiring writers to do
longer form pieces for my blog for
instance which does not have the draw or
cachet of The New Yorker certainly or
Wired but nonetheless decent amount of
traffic you know I had a couple million
people a couple couple of million
uniques per month and I think part of
what would struck me when I was trying
to think through this as someone who
loves long-form is that I didn't know
the process it's harder it's more of a
black box than trying to put together a
list of 12 bullets or a slideshow which
I'm not going to say it's mine yes
but it really doesn't require a lot of
planning so if for instance I wanted to
I had ideas for certain pieces and
wanted to invite people who had ideas
for pieces who were qualified writers to
do let's just call it three to ten
thousand word pieces right it's a very
broad spectrum what what is that process
then for figuring out how much I should
pay someone in a context like that
because you noted yourself there's kind
of a very wide this very wide spectrum I
think I just use that twice in like
three sentences shame on me but
nonetheless in terms of payment per word
I don't even know how that works because
I've never done it but how would you
think about going about doing something
like this if I wanted to do an
experiment like three to five pieces
with different writers and see how it
goes how would you suggest I even think
about this you that you have so much
experience and I have none because
everything on the blog with a few rare
exceptions have been my own stuff yeah
that's a really interesting question
it's kind of like what we went through
at the atomists so here are a couple
ways to fix wreck so first you could say
all right well how much advertising
revenue will I get and so you can do the
math right so let's say you have you
would get 50,000 people might read the
story that's a lot but you know you you
know through your social promotion and
to general traffic to the site so 50,000
people will read the story you will be
able to sell your ads that whatever eCPM
you sell let's say 15 dollars per
thousand visitors and you know you'll be
able to show four ads per person you
know one quarter of the people will be
turning on ad blockers so we'll say
three and how much revenue you generate
in total right as you go through those
calculations right you figure out what
is your sell to rate on the
advertisement so as you CPM is right and
the problem is when you do that
right if you add those numbers up you're
going to end up with you know generating
for your story that has a couple of ads
ads viewed per person
because people you're gonna end up
generating like $2,000 in total revenue
for the story right just the numbers are
just not good and so if you have an
advertising supported long form
journalism shop it's really hard to pay
for the writer and editor writes to the
art and sort of the bandwidth it's a
really hard thing to justify that's
something we thought through a lot at
The New Yorker and acquired and at the
animist okay so how do you make the
economics work if you're only going to
generate you know sometimes it's a
couple souter dollars in advertising
revenue like what book can you do well
the New York and wire there's a second
revenue stream with your subscriptions
right and so you generate way more money
from subscriptions on these long-form
stories than you do some advertisers so
suddenly the amount of total amount of
revenue generated by long story is much
higher alright so suddenly you're
generating you know $4,000 for a story
or $5,000 per story or whatever it is
you can justify paying higher rates the
third way of making money is like find
another thing so the atomistic was
Hollywood right where we could end up we
would pay writers I think we would pay
them more we had with different models
but you never be able to pay them much
better rates because you know if they
agreed that they will give you 50% of
the option price if they sell it to
Hollywood so we would bake that into our
contracts like you know either we can
pay you $2,000 for the story and you can
keep all the rights the Hollywood rights
or we can pay you $10,000 and give us
50% of the Hollywood money and then the
writer in Canada would choose the second
option to get the higher guaranteed
payment so they can justify spending all
the time on it so with you you might
want to think through something like
that or think through whether there's
another revenue stream you can attach to
whether it's being part of events or
something like that or find a specific
sponsors or a kind of story but that's
how I would think through the economics
of how to how to support it but again
the core problem and the reason why it's
really hard for publications to do long
form is that you know it takes a writer
two months to write a story that will
get 50,000 readers if you have that
writer putting out listicles they'll be
able to generate three of them a day
each of which will get 25,000 readers
and it's sort of the bang for the buck
equation unless you
to the economic somehow I having
subscriptions into videos or something
else all the economic incentives push
people towards short stuff yeah I'm I'm
in a somewhat odd position maybe in the
sense that I don't I don't have
advertising I don't have memberships I
there's a possibility I could do
something with Hollywood optioning there
are just stories that I would love to
have told and characters I know who are
just endlessly to me at least
fascinating who I don't have I don't
have current bandwidth maybe even the
capability to do justice in a really
long form piece and I would love to just
I want to just see it in the world and
pay them to do that probably reserve any
option right for film or anything like
that in the case that I'm paying them
how would you do how might you determine
how to pay them in a scenario like that
is there if you're prepared to lose
money on it then I'm prepared to lose
money but not like hemorrhage out the
face if that makes sense right like I'm
I want to pay in fear so you won't
hammer it out the face I mean pay people
$2 the word you'll get like all the best
writers in America will be really right
for you dunno you pay him a buck 50 a
word they'll be you know you'll get a
slightly smaller pool you play a lot the
people will be like yeah so yeah so your
range will be somewhere between $1 and
$2 a word cool you know if you're
Michael Lewis you'll ask for
substantially more but for like really
terrific writers they will be happy with
those rates cool amazing well alright
well I'm going to publicly say just for
any writers who are listening I will pay
you $2 a word given the ideas that I
have anything so yeah just and I mean
that may change but for the first few
pieces I want to do some some really
there's some things that I've been
thinking about and they've been eating
up like mother ramen my back of my mind
for probably a year or two and I think
they're people are better qualified to
tell some of these stories so cool
productive to podcast cool so I'll make
this well I guess it is called the Tim
Ferriss show so I shouldn't feel badly
about being so self indulgent but let me
move on
he also at the at the New Yorker the and
this was in Politico this is an
interview so this is I suppose when you
were senior editor and it said you'd
been responsible for shaping the 10,000
word raw copy filed by writers like and
and went on with this amazing list of
writers how how did you do what you did
as an editor how does one edit these
incredible writers who have ten thousand
word pieces like when you read a the
first four I suppose first of all do you
get a effectively finished piece do they
send you a first draft that is rough how
do these writers work with you or did
they work with you yet so it totally
varies right so the great thing about
the New Yorker is that you it's all
staff writer driven may be a unique
publication in America and that kind of
90% of the content is written by 50
people and so you show up and there
whatever there are six senior editors
that means that eight people work with
you so your life is about those eight
people so making sure that they have the
right ideas they're all working all the
time that you're helping them maximize
their talents their ambitions and
helping them find sports and so I worked
with a group of writers and with all of
them there were some things that would
be the same and some things that I would
do differently so first whatever they
file the draft I would immediately write
back and say that I've got it because
even if they're the most talented writer
in the world everybody is slightly
insecure and wants to know that their
story has been received by the editor so
I've got second thing is I would read it
but right then that I wouldn't delay
right because I just procrastination is
the enemy of good editing you should
just start and do it right and so if you
get the draft while you're in the middle
of something else important like I did
another draft of course you wait for now
but really you should you know within
the first you know six hours of getting
a draft from the writer you should have
read the draft and so then you read the
draft and then you start thinking
through and usually the first step would
be going through and sending them back a
memo saying hey this is good you know
these are the things I like but here are
the big structural issues and actually
giving them specific
guidance and my goal was always to make
it a memo that I wouldn't have to kind
of amend like you want to write and say
I haven't really figured this out but I
kind I think you might want to do this
I'll tell you more tomorrow
know you want them you want to give them
give them actual advice and things they
can work with that if they disagree they
can even have a conversation but I would
write a memo saying hey this piece is
strong so I really like this but I you
know I don't think you hit this core
issue I think that the chronology is
broken in these four ways I think you
overuse this and I really think you need
more reported on that and so for every
writer that's kind of the first step
which is here's what I think is wrong
with a piece and you you know you adjust
that based on the amount of time you
have a lot of it it's like a political
piece it has to run next week you you
know you try not to if they're only
going to be able to jump over something
that's four feet high the time available
you try not to set up a barrier that's
16 high okay so that's the first step
then after that it starts to really vary
depending on the writers so you know as
you know each edit you know you go
through a process from sort of wide
aperture big comments to very narrow
focusing on specific sentences at the
very end and the process by which you go
through that is different for different
writers so I worked with telus asana
one of the greatest post alice has ever
worked with and I would never adjust a
sentence of his of my own I would never
say why don't you write it this way I
would just say I don't think this works
please rewrite it or you know you know
please do this not redoing it I would
never I know never redo it myself but it
worked with a lot of other writers who I
would be much more likely to say yeah
maybe should read it this way or maybe
she do this way or even some writers
where I would go in and rewrite sections
with some writers remember I work with
Lionel ISM and you know he would always
been to this crazy deadline you have to
write there leading from behind story
and it has to run on Thursday and said
we would like literally be in Google
Docs where I would be rewriting the
beginning of the piece while he would be
writing the end of the piece it would
spend our whole weekend with him sort of
you know
filing down the story and me chasing him
as an editor and then him sort of like
cycling back up and going through my
edits and that's just sort of moving
through the piece with me trailing
behind him
there were different different processes
with different people but that's kind of
a guideline to how it works like I got a
much more specifics on that so it's one
of the things I absolutely loved do you
become a good writer first and then a
good editor do you have to or or can you
do it the other way around for people
who want to develop an eye for editing
I suppose which is also very very
closely related to rewriting
do you've any recommendations are there
any any books or classes or writers you
would pay attention to perhaps to people
who are listening to say you know what I
really want to develop a keener eye as a
writer / editor yeah so a couple of
things that I think are useful are well
okay first so how do we like get a
better sense of style in structure so
one of the things I think was really
important to me is that I found some
writers I really loved and I just read
their stuff out loud like that sort of
sources a level of concentration and
attention prose I remember
let's go through the pieces of this
Raider Catherine boo who loves New York
or I thought was maybe the best stylist
around and I would just read her pieces
out loud what was her name again tensed
which is Catherine boo how do you spell
B oh oh oh there we go
and she were a lot of pieces about
poverty her last book was about India
she doesn't write a ton but what she
writes was extraordinaire calluses na or
you can go back and do it you know with
John McKee you could go and do it with
gracefully for every year you know favor
it your favorite writer or stylist is or
even just a piece that you loved you
know we've had all kinds of teachers in
wire that are super interesting to read
if you read them out loud so find a
writer you love for whatever publication
and study them right and think about
what exactly are they doing I also you
know most of my training in this was
done as an editor but you could also do
it as a reader which is to map a story
so I will often on a whiteboard when I'm
working with a writer but you can also
just do it as an exercise put the
finished piece like look at the
structure I think
right so how exactly does it work where
is information presented where a
character is presented so I'll use this
example cuz it's sitting right here in
my desk like 11,000 word story about
Mark Zuckerberg that you mentioned at
the intro it has a very specific
structure that may not be the right
structure or may not be the ideal
structure but it is a very deliberate
structure so the way the story works is
several characters are introduced and
the story the first section of the story
is chronological from roughly February
of 2016 - I think it's April of 2016
it tells the story of Facebook during
that to look very and then the piece has
its one jump back because it tells very
quickly the story of Facebook from 2007
to 2016 and it introduces several
specific themes and a couple of
characters will become important later
that was very deliberately done then the
story jumps back into the chronology
picks up right where it was in April of
2016
introduces a couple of facts that will
be important later to the story and then
it mostly runs chronologically so it's
the structure is 80% chronological and
20% somatic you know at certain points
you have to introduce stories slightly
out of chronological order because of
where you are somatically in the story
that you're talking about Russia you
have to introduce in fact about Russia
even if it doesn't exactly fit the
timeline but my co-author for global
started I worked really hard to as much
as possible make it chronological is
very deliberate structural choice so you
could either map out that story and you
know by mapping it out learn the things
that I just said and also have a closer
sense of the moments where we chose to
break away from the chronology and then
be able to think through why we did that
and so you can do that with you know
most stories and you'll see flaws and
some of them you'll see brilliance and
some of them you'll see you know
chronological structures not
particularly interesting structure but
it's a very good one you'll see
interesting ways to do it you can do
watching movies too but I think it's a
really useful exercise it'll make you a
better writer and observer to take these
things apart when you map a story just
to use the tool you mentioned which is a
whiteboard what does it look like
visually mean is it kind of bullet
bullet bullet from top to bottom is it
set of circles going from left to right
with things inside the circles outside
the circles how do you map out a story
if you're doing it on a whiteboard it's
probably it probably has I mean they're
different ways to know the story but it
probably has two things it probably has
like section right so section a you know
the crime section B the chase right and
then so sort of titles for all the
sections and then sort of lines with the
different characters who are being
introduced and where they're being
introduced and maybe even the different
themes that are being introduced and
where they're where they're being
introduced so it's not really circles
it's more like it's more as close to the
bullet points recommendation I'd love to
make for people also this is this is
something I really need to revisit
myself although I'm not doing as much
writing at the moment but for people who
are really interested in structure and
this mapping of stories draft number
four by John McPhee is just a fantastic
read and it really gets into the weeds
so you have to be exceptionally
interested in writing to get into it but
it shows some of the diagrams of his
structures for various feature pieces
that that he's written including for The
New Yorker which is just I find
incredibly incredibly fascinating given
that if anyone has not read levels of
the game by John McPhee I would I would
cannot recommend it highly enough also
from a structural standpoint that sort
of chronology plus theme combination
just just a Finn just a wonderful
wonderful read you know you said she
said I'm in a tell story about Mickey
because he's the in some ways the reason
why I ended up working at The New Yorker
so I when I was at Wired as a senior
editor The New Yorker reached out and
said hey we you know we've heard you're
good senior editor we have it open in
would you like to applause and of course
I mean I loved Wired I love everything
about wire but in New York would be an
amazing challenge and so I applied and I
went to the process and the process was
you edit I'm ten thousand word stories
you rewrite things you it's exhausted
to be with a people and I went through
it and I didn't get it and but I could
kind of sense in the note that they sent
that I had been closed and then maybe so
that was probably I think this is 2009
it's probably October of 2009 and then
there was a holiday party in December of
2009 where I met somebody who had been
an assistant at The New Yorker and
they're like Nick Thompson oh my god
they went back and forth back and forth
they almost hired him didn't hire you
right so well that's interesting
information both is painful but it's
interesting I said then two months later
about February I had gotten um I knew I
was about to receive weirdly sort of two
other offers wanted to go into
television 101 for another magazine both
of which were very tempting and so I I
knew that I would be switching my career
soon and I remember staying up late one
night I read the the shape of the bar
can you just kind of unknown book but
just brilliant and it's like all the
feet work it it's so good as I read it
and I finished it I remember lying on my
couch it's like 2:30 in the morning and
I finished it I was so emotional asakim
I really I want to give the New Yorker
another shot before I before I totally
step away and so that night at 2:30 I
sent an email to the deputy editor Pat
McCarthy
that's like Pam or miss McCarthy um I
know you almost hired me you know four
months ago and I'm about to leave the
company wired as part of Wired where I
worked and where work that was part of
Conde Nast which is also part of us like
I'm about to lead the company to go
somewhere else but I really want to work
for you so this would be the moment and
I'd love to have another shot at it and
it was kind of a strange email to send I
was just sort of so emotional after
reading the key and Tamra back and was
like okay let's come meet with me again
and me with Remick again and so I went
upstairs to their office met with them
again when Nicholas can be blunt about
why he hadn't hired me the first time
asked me whether I could address the
concern he had the concern he had was
basically that you would comment on and
you want to write and do television and
do all these other stuff instead of like
this put
your head down and beaten editor I said
no I put my head down and be an editor I
can prove it to you she came into the
Edit test they gave me another edit test
and then you know probably a week or two
later they hired me
so it was entirely mcpeet that um that
you're spurred me to write that email to
Pam and then got me hired that's so
amazing what a great story oh my god
yeah I mean for people who really want
to go down that rabbit hole
I mean Brigade de cuisine there's so
many oh my god it's you you really can't
go wrong with with McPhee yeah no that's
that's a wonderful story how did you
decide to get into the startup game
startup game as a full-contact sport
generally very very difficult how did
that come into the fold so that happened
so I was an editor at Wired and and why
are you and Ramona Chris Anderson really
encouraged people to do different things
I have done this crazy wonderful story
where there's a writer at errata so I
added it at Wired awesome guy we had
gotten very drunk one night and we were
talking about for some reason there were
like a lot of people who are kind of
faking their death and starting life
over right which is the interesting
thing to do in the digital age because
it's kind of easier to start a new life
and create a new identity right just
create a new email address consider
comfort it's also easier to track people
so it's kind of an interesting wired
dilemma and we're talking about how to
tell us where were two other friends
okay Debra gray a woman GenCon four of
us ramen ceviche and alcohol and somehow
through this like long conversation Evan
came up with this idea which is that he
would write a story about how to fake
your death and start life over and then
we would run it and then he would say
his bath and we would run like a manhunt
to find him or not take his bath but
basically go off the grid and wired with
run a man on to find him this is early
Twitter and so we took that idea to the
wired pitch meeting it got a very high
score got approved
he wrote part one which is you know here
are some stories about people who've
tried to start over the digital age and
then he went on the run and so we ran
this experiment for a month this August
um I guess August 2009 and the
experiment was Evan Ratliff has
disappeared if you find him you get
$5,000 and then the rules were that I
would have all the information a private
investigator whereas so I would be able
to interview his family members I would
have access to his old photos I guess
social security number all those things
and I would leak them out to Twitter
over the course of the month and we had
no idea it was going to work
it was one of those things that like
I've maybe he'll get how on the first
day right or maybe no it will care but
through these you end up leaking his
social security number
I don't think I sleep I might add like
so much information about him I
certainly didn't put out his address his
name is XS like classical high school my
mother's name like all the stuff he
would have you know his credit card
bills and it was crazy people got so
excited and it all happened on Twitter
so the first time I was really into
Twitter and so the deal is via if he
made it a month he gets $5,000 he got
caught the person got $5,000 and so he
got caught because he was using porn to
disguise his IP address it's a masking
thing that make it possible for people
to see that IP address he'd use but he
screwed up once and by screwing up once
some smart coder figured out a little
bit about where he was then that guy
figured out the stake Twitter account
that evident created and followed it by
creating a fake fembot so we had a fake
for that much at all in editor Evans and
he somehow then figured out that edit
was in New Orleans we made a deal with
Will Shortz
that if you solved the New York Times
crossword puzzle embedded and it would
be a clue about where Evan was I think
the clue was something like he'll be in
a pizza restaurant and I had leaked
online who's gluten free so this is like
genius is online and like solved the
crossword puzzle and basically put
together that there's only one pizza
place you can go to in New Orleans which
serves gluten-free pizza and they caught
him on the last day was an amazing hug
yeah so that was really exciting and so
that happens and Evan and I of course
bond despite the fact that I perform
his life as the private investigator and
so maybe a month after that Evan and I
were two minutes after that we were
watching at his apartment watching a
football game like an Alabama college
football game
he's from the South was rooting for them
and he's like you know we should start a
magazine that does that kind of thing
oh sure that sounds like fun and I add I
just published that book and I had a
really good web designer kind of sky
named Jeff law I was like what's Jeff
and see whether he wants to do it with
us
and so the three of us got together we
said okay let's start a digital-only
magazine and so the idea was that I
would keep my job the two of them would
go full time to start the atomists we
would you know run experimental stories
crazy long-form stories and see what we
could do and then right about that time
Apple introduced the iPads and the idea
became though you kind of the iPad
focused and we'll do multimedia and so
we started this company at a super
propitious moment in order to create the
stories Jeff had to write a content
management system that would make
easiest for us to do multimedia
storytelling and so accidentally we
suddenly had a business to because then
we were able to license a content
management system to people so we built
a really cool business so the goal
hadn't been to start like a software
company in still don't know a software
company the goal had been just like
let's make a cool magazine that does
long form and we inadvertently built a
good business and so you know nine years
later we still got it it's still
publishing every month and there soon
we'll CMS they were still selling all
all good things start with ceviche and
alcohol what was the name of if you
recall the headline of the the title of
the piece about well I suppose it wasn't
about Evan at this point but about
people starting over in a digital world
do you recall or I don't know how many
people find they type in if they type in
wired vanish
it's all called in vanish you'll find it
so if you type in Evan Ratliff our HCl
is s I think the headline it's like in
Spanish and then Ratliff tried to
disappear here's what happened and it
will tell because after he was after you
got caught he wrote this great eight
thousand were story
his life on the run so good was the
first story from where I never nominated
for a National Magazine Award and
picture-writing
such a good story so yeah avid Ratliff
tried to vanish here's what happened and
did would looking for his name and
vanish also lead to the preceding piece
that he had written about okay very cool
yeah that's an ongoing fantasy although
increasingly difficult see you you might
by any objective measure have gotten a
lot done and get a lot done love to talk
about structure and routine not in
writing but in your life and this was as
good a place as any to ask do you still
run to and from work or how how long
yeah you do so alright so what I have
here is you run to work shower at the
gym next door and then you have suits in
the office to change into and then at
the end of the day you change back and
you run and close and run back home why
is that important to you have you always
been running out yeah so I was a runner
in high school in college
and then I took some time off and I
started sort of marathoning reasonably
seriously mid late twenties and it's
important for all times of reasons it's
important as a sense of self it's
important physically it's important you
know the hassle things one does is one
gets older and the marilee 40s now it's
important you know mostly because at one
point my life I got very sick and so
it's a reminder what I can still do it
that I'm no longer that so there are a
lot of like intense reasons why why I
run and why I like to run but it's
really hard to find time to run X I have
this conditions job I work super late
every night and I've got three kids and
I'm a very devoted father so I need to
be with them in the morning I need to be
with them in the evenings so I can't
kind of take off and run and in fact
it's often harder to find time to run on
weekends and isn't a weekday so having
it structured into my life
you know I put myself a wallet keys in a
little like little pack strapped it on
on you run home it works really nicely
and it keeps me I think it's also a good
mental break you spend the morning like
with the kids getting them ready you
know there's a lot of energy and
excitement and then when I go back home
there's a lot of energy excitement
putting them sleep them and kind of
going back to work so it's nice to have
like breaks in the day where I'm running
if you're open to talking about it you
mentioned you had a period me you got
very sick which which I don't know
anything about could you tell us a bit
more something about on internet I I got
thyroid cancer which is you know it's
cancer which is a horrible terrible
thing but it's a kind of the least
dangerous kind but what had happened
with running is sort of tell that whole
story then I started running and started
running marathons and like I remember
one break three hours I as a child I'd
lost my father he'd run a marathon I was
like three hours in 10 seconds and he
had like in frustrated that he couldn't
run a three hour marathon and so I
started running marathons and I like
couldn't crack it and then one year I
like totally cracked it and ran it's in
43 right it was like way underneath it
my dad was super proud and then right
after that I got diagnosed with thyroid
cancer and I've had in a couple of
surgeries going to radiation treatment
how did you diagnose it was a during a
routine checkup yeah I was like it was
like a couple weeks after the marathon
it was marathons in November I was in
early December and doctors like there's
a lump it's probably nothing but let's
check it and so he checked it and it was
like oh it might be bad you know then
you go through that whole process that
people have been sick go through where
you know oh no this could be bad but
I'll tidy okay and I'm in my twenties
I've always been healthy oh no it looks
like it might be bad oh no it is bad but
it won't be that bad oh no it is that
bad right and you better go through
through months of these tests and
experiments and biopsies as you either
like you either exit or you like it just
get ever deeper into it you know one
point I remember they thought
you're okay but any case so I went then
I went through like the surgery to have
it all removed and then the radiation
treatment and then the sort of titration
of the medicine to try to get you back
to normal and it just completely
obliterated me was the first time in my
life that I didn't just just knocked off
my feet and I couldn't like I couldn't
run you don't know like 15 feet right so
that was a really tough emotional period
for all kinds of reasons you know you're
thinking about mortality in a real way
for the first time in early 20s I had
just been married you know thinking well
now will I ever be able to have children
like what what your your expectations on
what life becomes are totally different
and so I went through that period and
fortunately came out the other side and
then it was really emotionally uplifting
and psychologically powerful and I guess
it was two years after that first
marathon I think in that first marathon
I finished it in like two hours 43
minutes in like 52 seconds and then like
two years later I ran the say marathon
and finished in like two hours 42
minutes 50 seconds or something like
that and it was you know incredibly
powerful to suddenly feel like in a way
that signal that I was through it and so
every year since then I have more or
less every year since then except two
years for bad kids I tried to run the
same marathon it that's tied you back to
the original story I don't run it well
thank you for sharing that happy to see
it's I think easy for for folks to look
at your bio or read about all the things
you've accomplished and assume that it's
just been one kind of home run after
another after another aside from that
kidnapping in northern Africa which
turned out to be a blessing in disguise
of sorts but I appreciate you sharing
that and to further sort of flesh out
the picture just a little bit could you
tell us about a time when you felt aside
from that particular period when you
felt overwhelmed or yeah or alright any
any of that and how you found your way
out I mean what you do in those
circumstances
well there been um you know my my
professional career in my you know the
first six or seven years was who's not
great I know so I I finish school I have
that kind of messed up period where I
you know go to ask I read the post but
it's you know it's a period of getting
rejected by twenty jobs before I get
hired the washed up okay so then there's
like a moment of Awesomeness where for
two years I'm editor to watch to monthly
going back to New York playing at on
weekends but to watch the multi job is
very much a two-year job and the
expectation when I finished was like all
previous editors and watched a monthly I
would go on and have an awesome career
in journalism I finished you know I
guess finished like September 9th 2011
and after I finished I had a really
rough time
I couldn't get hired I you know I got
rejected by 20 journalist institutions I
was sure I was going to higher than
their times I think entire look time
difference compared to Washington Post
you know I thought I had it just it
didn't work I ended up I admitted to
spell at the New America Foundation
which was fine but from roughly 2001 to
2005 I couldn't I couldn't get
journalism going again
and so in the summer of 2005 I guess in
2005 I was what kind of magazine called
legal affairs which other well like it
is really grateful to but it wasn't
because in New Haven my girlfriend is
that my wife was in New York I you know
I applied to law school which is the way
you get out of journalism right in the
way you retrack your life right if
you're in your twenties and the career
you're doing is not working one great
way to be track your life is through law
school so I applied to law school and I
got into NYU and I was literally set to
go I guess I would have matriculated in
August of 2005 I think wired wrote to me
in July of 2005 saying hey were you just
admitted senior editor and so that
summer it was crazy right because my
whole life he's gonna I know it's gonna
hinge on this decision right am I going
to stay in journalism and or am I going
to go to law school and then like do
something completely different
and the way it you know check out I
remember the that I hadn't I don't think
I had been offered the wire job but I
was pretty sure I was going to get it
and so the day before I was doing NYU I
wrote shows and then I'm not going and
then I prayed oh my god and I did get it
and I started that next month but it was
that was like those were a couple years
for a second time make the right
decision like because remember when I
had been like a teenager I hadn't
expected to be a journalist so I had all
this self-doubt about whether I had
ended up in the wrong profession
accidentally where because if you look
at your life as you know the person when
you're 25 and you think back to what
would Nick if not at 19 the the funny
turn into journalism which now seems so
propitious and so good consider the
weird story were kidnapped and I read
the story and get hired the wash them up
in it attracts me like if you look at it
from now it looks like a really
fortunate thing that those things happen
but if you're in your mid-20s and
journalism isn't working and you look at
it and think wait I wasn't supposed to
be a journalist I didn't want to be a
journalist so maybe that just all got me
going on the wrong foot and I should
have like I hadn't gone Africa now it
would be in a much better place so that
was really complicated to think through
and work through it and ended up all
working out really well and I'm
extremely happy where I am now but that
was there was definitely a couple years
where I was totally adrift where my peer
group was doing much better than I was
doing and where I felt like I was in the
wrong field
how did wired find you or how did how
did it come to pass that they reached
out to you with that potential offer
because I have a friend for whom I've
had like a sort of amazing career
overlap there's a guy named Brendan
Carter and I are exactly the same age
and I edited something he wrote at when
I was at the Washington Monthly he was
at US musical reporting with us it works
and I edit it and he liked the way I
edited it and so we became friends and
so then he left us news and got hired at
the American Foundation and then I got
hired at New America Foundation after
him and he had recommended me and then
he went to wired and he recommended me
there
so I got hired at Wired and I
recommended him to my book agent and he
ended up selling a book through that and
then he will commute to New Yorker and
will commit the animist and he's got the
cover story in Wired so we've had these
amazing intertwined careers in
friendship it's been really terrific and
he's one of those people who you know
with some people who are like the same
age and in the same field
they're like competitive and maybe don't
always want you to succeed and for
whatever reason he and I have had a
relationship where I've always owned a
lot of him was succeeding he's only
always wanted me to succeed and so we've
been extremely helpful to each other and
that's been that's been great and so
look at the cover story the next issue
and Brendan's name is there and I'm
super proud of it yeah the karmic cycle
continues that's great
yeah I want to I want to go back to the
whatever it was 24 hour period where
you've turned down this exploding offer
slash expiring offer for Law School
yet you haven't yet you haven't yet been
offered the job at Wired can you walk us
through the the dinner the conversation
in your head the sort of hours preceding
notifying law school that you were not
going to be matriculated yeah because
that is that strikes me is terrifying
that seems completely terrifying I mean
the game theory was both a little
trickier and in some ways easier because
there was a third option I had written
my grandfather Thomas had died and
George Kennan had both died in early
2004 and I had written an essay about
their parallel lives and so I had also
decided that maybe I would write a book
about the two of them and so I had
proposal for a book so I had three
things that I could do with my life and
I was going to do some combination of
one of those three things or two of
those three things I mean it wouldn't be
time to do all three you can't go to law
school work for Wired and write a book
and so the law school offer was can
explode mid-august
the wired option I was going to hear
about relatively soon and the book I
think I had sent it
a little proposal to my agent and so
either that we can become a reality or
not a reality and so in some ways the
decision was if I go to law school even
if I don't get the wire job I still
maybe have a shot at the book so the
odds were like the odds are okay but I
you know what do I remember about that
day I was in Maine up at a place my
family has up near Acadia National Park
where it's been so much to my childhood
which is like a very reflective
wonderful place for the place where I
always feel good and confident I maybe
was being there maybe it was you know I
there was some unease and some deep
unease about going to law school some
sense that I was giving up some sense of
but you know it was the the week choice
to make I don't exactly remember but I
do remember being terrified when I wrote
them and said no and thinking well this
is you know you came up with a pretty
good backup here and a cue you know 30
to plan anybody it's a pretty awesome
law school to go to it's three years and
you're you know you graduate you're
guaranteed a really well-paying
successful career in life in New York
and you're throwing that away but I went
for it
I thank God for that I suppose yeah it
seems to have worked but I didn't think
about a lot right like that was like
their very few moments where your life
entirely hinges upon a specific decision
right like the choice of who you married
but it's not really a choice you know
it's not so much like that like it is I
can't think of any other day and that's
close to it I mean guess the choice to
right Pam McCarthy at The New Yorker had
a big influence you know there was the
choice to lead to be a New Yorker to
accept this wire job that was pretty
easy choice towards a New Yorker but you
got to be editor-in-chief of are you
definitely take it so there there are a
few moments but that was definitely the
day where I made the choice that had the
biggest effect but you don't get to you
know live like multiple ways so it seems
like the right choice everything worked
out as well as it possibly could have
but who knows
well Nick I want to be respectful of
your time so I just have just a few more
questions for you and these are these
are my some of my usual questions that I
like to ask but the first is what book
or books have you given most as gifts to
other people besides your own oh that's
that I can answer so this year some each
of the last two years I've given one
book to a bunch of people and this
year's book by Robert Wright called why
Buddhism is true and it's a story about
mindfulness and about the science of
Buddhism and the current neuroscience
about how our minds work making your
argument that you know the things people
have said about mindfulness meditation
and the way it changes your capacity to
emphasize that other people are just a
break out of the tribalism that we're
all walked into the things that Buddhism
has said about that turned out to be
scientifically correct and here's a
story about one wonderful book Robert
Wright is one of the smartest writers
that I read his book non-0 is among my
favorite books of all time so that book
came out recently and I gave that to my
closest friend and my family the year
before I gave a book by the rest'
MacFarquhar
called strangers drowning which is a
story about people who make
extraordinary moral choices like the
choice to adopt 23 children and bring
them into your lives
you just make crazy choices and why they
make those choices and larysa is one of
the smartest writers at the new yorker
everything she writes is absolutely
brilliant in the book is brilliant
beginning to have sort of 10 discrete
chapters about people who make choices
like that so I gave Larissa's book last
year and Karl Wright's book this year
thank you just wrote those down yeah
they're good
totally worth reading both of them yeah
no they're they're on the on the to read
list which is always on the bottom
right-hand corner of my notes that I
take during these conversations yeah
yeah just a few more sam picking picking
here in the last and last few years
could be five years could be ten could
be - what behavior new behavior or
belief has most improved positively
impacted your life would you say or has
just had a
very significant impact well having kids
you know so my kids are nine seven and
four now and thinking about the
responsibilities one has you your
children who will outlive you and who in
certain ways will carry on your
personality you carry on your life after
they're gone thinking through my
responsibilities to them how the choices
I make err will be viewed by them when
they're older thinking about those how I
can help them thrive and be the people
they want to become and also how I can
be somebody who when I'm gone they
admire those are theirs are pretty those
are deeply profound things and you know
I had no capacity of what it was like
that children before I had chosen like
none but it's it's psychologically
profound one in every everywhere so
definitely that there any advice or
books or anything else that you found
particularly helpful as a parent wait I
don't you know I don't think I'd
actually read a book on parenting that
changed my philosophy of parent I mean
they're a couple of books about how to
get your kids to sleep which is like
useful technical stuff I haven't read
you know that's interesting I don't
think I've read a book on parenting as I
go I should raise my child that way or I
should talk to them this way it's been
much more just just doing and just
thinking through oh wait that wasn't the
right way to talk about this or oh yes
let's try to set them you know set them
up for success in this way or like let's
let them do this so let's let's go do
this with them do you have a do of a you
mentioned the why Buddhism is true do
you have a meditation or mindfulness
practice I don't um I kind of think the
running is the substitute for that and
what I'm running I do it's very much I
don't think it's that this similar from
mindfulness meditation because when I
run every week us or two things I'd say
that one is the running so you know
dairy much try to add it was in the
podcast or if I'm not listen to podcast
I'm thinking about like trying to clear
my mind or it can get to specific things
and try to concentrate on it or paying
attention to what I see or what I hear
so I think that's as
reasonably close to mindfulness
medication and then the second thing is
I do Alexander Technique which is a
technique I learned for playing a car
just for how one positions one by one's
body and like online in your head to
make sure it's straight but your back
and making sure your feet of solid in
the crown notice something I did when I
was having a lot of wrist pain some
playing guitar too much and I think
that's that's a sort of the century
techniques that also plays a similar
similar role but I have you know I have
not figured out how to work meditation
into my life the Alexander Technique is
that something that you use while you're
sitting in a chair at the office
throughout the day when does that okay
yeah so something I think about of
course as soon as I say it identify
myself like adjusting myself in the
chair yeah it's something where whatever
I'm kind of out of position or I can
feel like something's not aligned I you
know straighten up
say don't try to think about where I
lost hands right I just need you just
okay make sure my back is aligned my
head is aligned and it's something that
I think has prevented a lot of injuries
I almost have never gotten hurt while
running so you know run run in a
distance that awesome get people hurt
and I think it's partly due to posture
training mm-hmm it's just uh just two or
three more there and this this is
sometimes a question that stumps people
but you've been heading back pretty fast
in your feed so if you need to buy some
time or pass that's fine as well
if you could have a if you had this is
really metaphorically speaking a giant
billboard on which you could put a word
a question a quote someone else's quote
a question anything really a message to
get out to millions or billions of
people what might you put on that
billboard you know what it is I'm not
gonna get the exact quote right which
you know means I have to spellcheck it
but there's something that George Kennan
said that I just find like incredibly
philosophically profound
which is something I think about a lot
not enough to remember the exact words
but the idea was when you look at
everything that goes wrong historically
you can see a deep chain of continuous
mistakes that lead up to it and in a way
that's really discouraging because it
makes me think about like each step like
leading to greater consequences
but on the other hand it's really
encouraging because if you think about
it and you think about oh wait what if
you do something right can you do
something right right now
you're starting a whole another chain
after that secondly to really positive
outcome and so his point when he was
making the statement which is more or
less that is even if things seem like
they're going in the wrong direction or
things seem really wrong like you can
stop and you can do something small
that's right and then that will begin
another chain of events that will lead
to something really good and so I often
think about that when I'm thinking about
whatever the next thing I'm going to do
is or the next moment is right you just
are you're giving a new chain of events
a chain of events that will lead you in
the right directory you're continuing in
a good chain so it was it was bad idea
from 10 and that was based on his
historical studies that I think about a
lot that's a good one
well Nick this has been a lot of fun and
yeah it's been great thank you thank you
for taking the time give any final words
and he asked of the audience
recommendation anything you'd like to
say before we wrap up no I I love
talking to you I mean this thing I want
people to subscribe to wire that'd be
great
everybody subscribes to Wired I'll be a
very happy man journalism is a
complicated business particularly at
this moment so we would love your
support and if they want to say hi
on social NX come on so I talk to people
all the time I'm at a TEDx Thompson on
Twitter I'm on LinkedIn I'm on Facebook
there's a private page another page I
love talking to people I love hearing
feedback I'm very active in comments and
all that dn0 and so I'm available I'm
around I'm on the Internet
well Nick thank you again for taking the
time this is a really fun conversation
ya know we covered a lot of interesting
grounds thanks for your awesome
questions and probing I was really
really fun detective yeah of course my
pleasure and everybody listening you can
find links to everything wired the books
resources and the Alexander Technique
among other things and in the show notes
as per usual for this episode and every
other episode of tim dot blog forward
slash podcast and until next time thank
you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode's brought to you by peloton and
I'd heard about peloton over and over
again but I ended up getting a peloton
bike in the whole system after I saw my
buddy Kevin Rose I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic hey I asked was a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to but she's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home
you have to worry about fitting classes
in your schedule or making it to a
studio with some type of commute etc new
classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
wilfers and his eye on high-intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet too believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys
thus nurse of the Tim Ferriss show a
special offer and it is actually special
visit one peloton that's o-n-e PE l OT
on1 peloton calm and enter the code Tim
all caps TI m at checkout to receive
$100 off accessories with your peloton
bike purchase now you might say bet
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory categories so this
hundred dollars off is a very legit
hundred dollars off so if you want to
get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out pillowtop one pallet uncom and
enter the code to Tim
again that's Ont PL o-- t om dot-com and
enter the code tama check out to receive
$100 off any accessories including the
shoes that you will want to get check it
out
one peloton comm code Tim this episode
is brought to you by LinkedIn and their
job recruitment platform which offers a
smarter system for the hiring process
if you've ever hired anyone or attempted
to do it you know that finding the right
people can be extremely difficult and if
you don't have a direct referral from
someone you trust you're left to use job
boards that don't really offer any
real-world networking approach and we
mean by that is in contrast
LinkedIn which is the world's largest
professional network has a built in eco
system that allows you to not only
search for employees but also interact
with them and their connections and
their former employers or colleagues in
a way that closely mimics real-life
communication more than 70% of the
workforce in the u.s. uses LinkedIn and
more than 22 million professionals view
and apply to LinkedIn every single week
unlike generic job boards LinkedIn
considers skills experience and location
to match it with candidates making it
easier to find quality candidates and
maybe above all you can directly contact
a candidate's connections to get a good
sense of if they are a good fit for your
business
so visit LinkedIn compote slash Tim and
receive a $50 credit towards your first
job post that's linkedin.com forward
slash tim t IM for $50
you
you